معركه باخمه تدخل مرحله جديده او منعطفا
جديدا بعد الامدادات العسكريه البشريه
التي وصلت الى محيط مدينه باخمت الحديث من
بريجوجن مؤسس قوات فاغنر بان القوات
الاوكرانيه يعني لا تلعب في هذا المحور
انها تعزز قدراتها من الناحيه الغربيه ومن
الناحيه الشماليه الحديث عن اربع قواعد
عسكريه كبيره اوكرانيه في محوري الشمال
حيث صلابيانس وسيفرس وفي المحور الغربي
حيث قسطنطينه
عدا عن البلدات الصغيره التي باتت القوات
الاوكرانيه تعزز قدراتها فيها حسب
قوات فاجنر الذي طالب بمزيد من الذخيره
ومن الدعم العسكري كما انه لابد من
الاشاره هنا الى ان قائد ايضا قال طالب
بمزيد من المجندين واضحا
عناوين في العاصمه الروسيه موسكو للالتحاق
بمجموعات فاجنر القتاليه من اجل تعزيز
قوات العمل في مدينه باخمون بالفعل ايضا
هذه القوات الاوكرانيه تريد ان تجعل طوق
فوق الطوق الروسي نقصد الناحيه الشماليه
خالد يعني الناحيه الشماليه تسيطر عليها
قوات فاجنر الروسيه والشرقيه والجنوبيه
القوات الاوكرانيه بنت من الشمال والغرب
الغرب هو محور اوكراني بحث لكن الشمال هو
محور روسي وبناء قوات اوكرانيه فوق القوات
الروسيه قوات فاجنر هذا يعني انهم يريدون
تطويق قوات فاجنر من الناحيه الشماليه ومن
داخل باخمت ايضا من الناحيه الشماليه وهذا
ما اشار اليه بريجوجن مؤسس فاجنر بان
يجب ان تستمر قوات فاغنر بالعمل وبالقتال
ويجب ان تنتصر لان خساره قوات فاجنر في
هذا المحور يعني خساره
خساره كبيره للجيش الروسي او للعمليه
العسكريه هذا جانب جانب الاخر زياره وزير
الخارجيه الروسي سرقه شوكو خلال اليومين
الماضيين يعني كان في المنطقه الجنوبيه
وشمال غرب
المقاطعه هنا في دانيه زارا مناطق مختلفه
منها افديف كمارينكا
مخالفه كوزاره الدفاع لان الجيش الروسي
ايضا يعمل في محاور مختلفه محور
كوبيانس كليمان هذه المحاور عاده القوات
الروسيه وتقدمت فيها من جديد بعد ان خسرت
هذه الاراضي مطلع العام
الجديد بالفعل عادت والان هي تقاتل على
تخوم مدينه كوبيانس من اجل اعاده السيطره
على كوبيانس بالفعل
المعارك مستعره هناك نقص بالذخيره عند
الجانب الاوكراني يعني نفس الاوكراني
الاوكرانيون نفسهم يطالبون بمزيد من
الذخيره ويشكون من نقص الذخيره قوات فاجنر
من الواضح بانها تعمل بعنف في محور باخ مت
ولديها ذخير لكنها دائما ما تطلب المزيد
على لسان مؤسس القوات